[Music]
foreign
for the Press preview it's our first
look at what is on tomorrow's up front
pages and tonight we'll have a look at
those front pages with the journalist
and author Christina Patterson who's
joined by the political editor of the
Scottish Sun Rachel Watson never good
evening to both of you uh we'll speak to
them in a moment but first of all let's
have a look at those front pages for you
beginning with the Sunday Times I'm the
PM who will get brexit done says sunac
the paper leads with those defiant words
by the prime minister
Johnson over New brexit Deal the Sunday
Telegraph focusing on The Showdown with
his former boss
The Daily Mirror leads with a plea to
Rishi sunak by a Ukrainian boy to be
reunited with his father in the UK amid
a backlog of thousands in the
government's homes for Ukraine scheme
let's bring in your Sunday Express
reporting on ministers planning to crack
down on lawyers representing migrants in
Asylum claims
while figures obtained by The Observer
suggest around one in every hundred
police officers in England and Wales
faced criminal charges last year
and on the front page of the star a
story that Satanist groups are holding
Bake Off contests in a bit to attract
more members
and don't forget you can scan that QR
code that you see on screen during the
program check out the front pages of the
papers while you watch us discussing
them and to discuss them journalists and
author Christian Patterson and political
editor of the Scottish Sun Rachel Watson
right let's get cracking shall we
Christina why don't you kick things off
um lots of talk about a potential brexit
deal being imminent maybe tomorrow maybe
Monday if things go according to the
prime minister's plan the Sunday Times
uh has had an interview with him and he
says I'm the PM who will get brexit done
in something of a a dig I guess to one
of his predecessors
yes well
I think the thing about Rishi sunic
sunac is that he is rather more of a
realist than his predecessor who seemed
to think that things could just be done
through Pure Fantasy and willpower not
his willpower obviously but his mental
willpower so he thought that you could
have
um a deal a brexit deal that meant that
the Northern Ireland could maintain
sovereignty and there could be no border
with the EU and clearly he was living in
Cloud Cuckoo Land and that was quickly
proven to be the case and he actually
promised people in Northern Ireland
there would be no checks on goods and
there would be no border anywhere which
obviously was a promise he couldn't make
which he then wrote so Rishi sunak has
been left with this problem along with
millions of other problems and he has
been sitting down with Ursula Laden and
various other
um EU uh sort of you know the the kind
of the people wielding the power and in
a position to do the negotiating in the
EU and it looks so he has managed to
secure a deal that that ticks most of
the boxes in that Northern Ireland will
maintain sovereignty and there will be
relatively few checks on Goods those
going destined for Ireland it seems
we'll have to have some checks because
Ireland is part of the EU but it looks
as though there will be expedited lanes
for goods destined for supermarkets in
Northern Ireland which should make
things much easier and needless to say
the usual people who froth at the mouth
the ERG the dup and Boris Johnson who
just enjoys frothing at the mouth
because it's what makes them happy to
draw attention to himself are going mad
and Boris Johnson is harboring fantasies
of using this as a way back into number
10 and hopes that he can bring some kind
of Face Off with uh with Rishi sunak
which um I don't think will happen I'm
sure there'll be some kind of rail but I
don't think Boris Johnson will get back
to number 10 and I don't think the
country wants him back in power so um I
suspect this will pass slaber said they
will support it and that will be a
victory for sunac and well done for him
for grappling with reality and not this
kind of parallel universe that we've
been living in for the last few years
okay
um certainly that interview in the times
Rachel is is very defined by the Prime
Minister but do you think this agreement
will be accepted by the dup it's also as
Christina was saying it's going to need
the backing of those that Tory back
benches in the ERG
yeah there are so many problems for
vicious tuna here you know just getting
a deal is the first step and then
getting it through getting the support
behind it is step two and I think that's
why we've seen if you look at the Sunday
Times interview there's words from the
Prime Minister also on the telegraph
really I moved my wishes you next to try
and get ahead get one foot out in front
of people like Boris Johnson and others
who might be planning a rebellion you
know the Telegraph and mentioned that
Steve Baker might be on a resignation
watch at the moment over this they
mentioned some other names as well uh
warnings of Civil War within the party
and they did mention again dup in the
fact that there are concerns that if the
dep don't back this then they won't go
to storm and have those negotiations
about power sharing and that is a huge
problem for vicious sinek there's a huge
you know it will be a huge queue if he
managers to to get this deal and then
get it through Boris Johnson it's not
his only predecessor who has had huge
problems in negotiating some kind of
deal
over Northern Ireland you know since the
brexit but we've had uh Theresa May uh
Boris Johnson Les Charles and I wish you
sooner trying to get somewhere with this
uh Liz truss obviously didn't have very
much time at all to do anything but
um very a number of prime ministers who
try and work over this and I think
um this is a clear move by the prime
minister to try and get in front of
those people and and say to them if you
look at some of the words used by Russia
and that he believes in brexit he
campaigned for bricks that he voted for
bricks and he wants to see this go
through but he also talks about the
people in Northern Ireland businesses in
Northern Ireland who need a deal and
he's trying to make that appeal to his
colleagues to the dup and to The Wider
population who voted for brexit that
actually you know the promises that were
made before as Christina mentioned were
not deliverable by the UK government and
this is and this will hopefully go some
way to solving those problems and it's a
real move by the prime minister to try
and get that out before people like boy
Johnson and Steve Baker and other people
who might be unhappy with this can then
go back out and breathe against him in
this deal yeah it's a really interesting
point you make
um there isn't it Christina
um and something that stood out for me
in that interview in the Sunday Times
was when Richie sunak said
um about the the awful shooting that
happened uh recently sort of reminding
us he said of the delicate situation in
Northern Ireland the fragility of it and
we shouldn't take it for granted there
is a there is a huge amount resting on
this you know there's a lot of talk
about sausages and all the rest of it
but actually that there's so much more
uh to this which means that it has to
work
and that's why that's why it was so
utterly immoral for Boris Johnson to use
this really of the play thing as a way
for him to bolster his power and His
Image and to be a kind of ostensibly a
hardliner on brexit and then betray
absolutely everybody involved because
people died and and somebody nearly died
this week in that killing I mean I think
to take so likely what was actually a
war a Civil War in Northern Ireland I
mean I I was I grew up in Guildford I
remember my I remember the the pub
bombings in in Guildford these were real
atrocities that happened we lived in
fear of them even in the in the in
London in the in the mainland and uh
that was you know that was not very long
ago and as Joe Biden has made very clear
this the most important thing was has
been to preserve peace in in Northern
Ireland and and indeed here because the
lack of peace had ramification is here
and they took that the Tories have taken
that very very likely so I think I don't
think Rishi Suna is the best person at
the politics in terms of handling the
dup or the ERG though I do think the ERG
and the gup for that matter are pretty
impossible to handle because uh they're
just not very rational about these
things but I I do think he understands
you know the kind of real life
ramifications in a way that those people
tend not to so I have to say you know
let's give credit where it's due okay
well let's see what happens uh in the
next 24 48 Hours um I just want to move
on before the break uh Rachel to a story
in the Observer
um which the paper is saying insiders
have told them that the labor party is
now debt and deficit free after this two
million pound donation
yeah this is a kind of positive weekend
for labor if you look at some of the
headlines that have been generated by
them as you see this piece in the
Observer they say that David sainsbury
has donated two million pounds to the
party and which not only that two
million pounds is a huge boost to the
party finances when we've got a general
election year coming up
um even though we're only at the start
of 2023 minds are very much on that next
general election and but also this is a
business boss who's coming and is back
in the labor party with a substantial
donation something that they will want
to do and there's a huge belief within
labor in Scotland and the rest of the UK
that they will be the next government
that they will win the next election
and we're still you know a bit out from
that general election but they've got
the belief there
um and and that's what they want to do
and and there's concern within the
conservatives and there'll be more
concerned when they see the fact that
business now is looking to the labor
party and giving these donations but
also those other headlines this weekend
that I mentioned was Luciana Berger I'm
joining the labor party again she
obviously left under Jeremy corbyn and
around the time when there was Rouses in
the labor party about anti-Semitism and
having her back is very symbolic for the
labor party insecure starmer and really
does give them that boost that the party
is moving on from those fractures that
really um divided the party and really
took all that you know that's what we
were talking about labor for for so many
years for months we were talking about
those divisions the problems they had
within the party the internal struggle
and now we're talking about these huge
huge Nations backing from business and
the fact that circus demer and others in
the party have that belief that they
will win the next general election
Christina
yeah it's I mean you can almost feel the
tectonic plates shifting uh here's
Thomas the care stamma when he spoke
this week about his five
um goals for labor he had that Sheen of
power he looked like a prime minister I
think he's I think he's beginning to
feel like a prime minister in waiting
and the fact that business are flocking
to labor says everything really and and
who can blame them because brexit and
the Tories have been absolutely
disastrous for for business and when
Christina by those those five missions
were was there enough detail there for
you
well I mean look
we've got to give great detail at this
point because uh he doesn't know what
money will be available and also he
doesn't want his policies to be nicked
by the Tories this week when it happens
when labor comes up with good ideas so
he's just his job now is to seem
electable and he's doing a pretty good
job at that and I think his detox
defying of Labor over anti-Semitism and
in refusing Jeremy corbyn being able to
run again I think all of this is is
beginning to have the effect that the
electorate are trusting him and all of
that is absolutely vital so I think I
think he's doing well and I think that
as things look at the moment they will
win the next election and thank goodness
for that all again part two of The Press
preview with Rachel and Christina Rachel
a couple of um very interesting uh quite
disturbing stories actually regarding uh
the police and crime one on the front of
the Observer one on the front of the
Sunday Times The Observer
saying that one in 100 police faced
criminal charges in 2022 which is is
remarkable isn't it um let's talk about
that one first then we'll go on to the
the one in the times
yeah as you say a really remarkable
Story the figures on her so Stark and
it's another one of these stories that
are becoming really we're seeing them a
lot at the moment there's been stories
in Scotland as well about that
confidence in the police and how much
confidence can people have in the police
at the moment so this story is that
1387 claims were made to the police
Federation for legal support for
criminal charges now we don't know we've
only seen the bet on the front of the
paper on the front of the Observer so we
don't know the severity of these charges
there's no detail what they are but does
talk about a near 600 rise in 10 years
in these claims for support and I think
it feeds into this as I said and this
talk over the last couple of years about
the confidence we can have and the
police there's been such high profile
cases I remember the Sarah everard case
which was a really horrific example
um of police and and
um and and you know a really horrific
case there and that happened with a
serving police off so and there's been
other cases
um not not to that severity but it
really called into question that the
culture of them police and the vetting
because we know that the majority of
officers and obviously go out there and
serve and do their job to protect people
and but there have been questions around
the vetting and the culture uh within
place that these cases and that they
even occur
um let alone the fact that we you know
we don't care about them um until it's
often that they're going through Court
um and these people are are still
serving police officers
yeah I mean Christina you know
regardless of the uh the severity of the
charges it's still a a desperately
worrying figure
it's absolutely horrific really horrific
and one of the really worrying things
about this this story and I have to say
I've had this sense before is that the
police Federation which is like the sort
of the Union of the police except that
you automatically join the police
Federation when you become a police
person
um thank
this seems to sense that they are have
essentially been supporting police
almost irrespective of whether they uh
you know that the bias has been towards
supporting police let's say rather than
supporting the law which is pretty
shocking and if you found one percent of
any Workforce to have committed
um a criminal act that would be pretty
shocking but for the police I I have to
say I have the sense at the moment that
faith in the police to protect people is
at something like an all-time low and
the general sense actually in this
country at the moment is that all our
public services are failing us for
different reasons but the sense of
corruption and criminality and sexism
and misogyny and violence endemic in the
police force has absolutely ruptured
faith in the police particularly for
women in a way that it'd be very hard
for them to come back from so um it's
it's deeply deeply shocking yeah and I
did mention a second story as well it's
on the front of the Sunday Times Rachel
this is about low level crime and police
failing to charge any suspect
yes the the Sunday Times have figures on
reports of public threats abuse or
harassment and and they say that just
three percent of these led to someone
being charged and again it feeds into
what Christine and I were just talking
about about public confidence in police
and this wider conversation about and
public services and what is happening
um there and you know people will read
this story and and be questioning the
legal system if you are the victim of a
crime you want to make sure you want
that to be dealt with charges to be
brought in for that for to see that go
through Court
um but it seems here that again you know
Can people really depend on that at the
moment okay and let's finish with the
front of the telegraph uh Christina now
we've heard a lot a lot haven't we in
the last few days about uh Roald Dahl
books and changes being made to them uh
to suit perhaps the sensitivities of of
current readers now James Bond books are
being edited
yeah I mean I have to say I'm a bit uh
as a Californian would say conflicted on
this one I thought the role of doll I I
didn't approve of that I think
forgiveness that you can't keep
rewriting writers we're all the products
of our time culture changes all the time
in 25 years culture would have changed
again and most of the things we in many
of the things we regard as sort of you
know deeply politically correct now will
be deemed completely you know sort of
outrageous in 25 years time but having
looked at the recommendations for the
the James Bonds which are largely to do
with racism or kind of almost porn sort
of pornographic sexism I sort of feel
okay James Bond is sort of a franchise
and the films themselves have changed a
lot over the years so you know I
remember the watching James Bond films
as a child and they would be absolutely
unacceptable in terms of political
correctness today so I kind of
understand why these changes have been
made but I think it's a slippery slope
you know are we going to start censoring
Shakespeare in Jane stain and certainly
the sense amongst some youngsters and I
don't mean this in a drogatory way to
them but again to do with cultural
shifts is that everything has to be kind
of edited sensored trigger full of
trigger warnings and actually we just
have to be in many ways more comfortable
with with reading stuff that we don't
necessarily agree with but I think stuff
you know James Bond that stuff that
really starts
probably racism I can absolutely see why
people felt it was necessary to make
some minor changes there yeah um and a
very quick thought Rachel on this 20
seconds
yeah I agree completely with that as
well and you know I think the language
when you read this the article and the
language that has been used and
suggested to change and you know you can
see there's these questions over where
whether you know will people continue to
read these books if if you don't make
that change what were the thoughts on
those be so I think
um you know it is a slippery slope
there's a wider discussion to be had on
on where that line lies too